[Music]
a new report says an autopsy concluded
that carbon monoxide poisoning led to
the deaths of three american tourists at
a sandals resort in the bahamas earlier
this month the victim's family is now
asking for a second independent autopsy
in their search for answers here to
weigh in fox news contributor dr marty
mccary doc should the families of the
victims be satisfied with this report or
should they be skeptical and want a
second autopsy
well they should be a little skeptical
that toxicology reports have actually
not been released they should ask to see
them but we do know that carbon monoxide
poisoning does kill about 400 to 500
people a year and it is something that
does happen and there may be a plausible
mechanism if you put all the pieces
together in the circumstances of what
happened yeah i'm trying to figure that
out trying to visualize a standard hotel
room where would carbon monoxide come
out of the various things that are in a
hotel room my first instinct is the
heater air conditioner but anywhere else
i mean it's possible that a gas oven or
range could release carbon monoxide it
could be that there's a garage where
cars are parked within the building and
perhaps a channel by which that gas
could go into the room so those are all
possibilities when you heard that
pesticide theory from people in the
hotel saying they smelt a strong smell
of pesticide carbon monoxide has no
smell pesticide obviously in many cases
does
would you travel down that path and do a
little bit more research on the
pesticide angle because to me if other
people were smelling that that could be
cause for concern at least in my
estimation
that's right look that's a very good
point todd and i think you have to
assume it's an environmental exposure
until proven otherwise carbon monoxide
is classically odorless
and a colorless gas so you would not
expect any odor so the pieces really
right now don't fit together
if they had called for help like they
did i mean they weren't feeling real
great they went inside got some
treatment could they have been saved or
at some point is your body just so
compromised that nothing can be done
once carbon monoxide enters your system
well first of all carbon monoxide
poisoning does
act really quickly people
within a matter of minutes can lose
consciousness and the treatment is
pretty simple get people to a better air
source so it is possible that even a
matter of seconds could have made a big
difference in trying to help these
individuals a complete tragedy so many
answered unanswered questions still at
this point meantime you are calling out
a cdc advisory panel for approving covet
boosters for kids as pfizer is looking
to jab kids as young as six months why
are you coming out so strongly against
this panel doc
well again the biden administration's
fda was completely bypassed in convening
their technical experts their advisory
committee these are the top vaccine
experts in the country many had signaled
that they're not on board with this
recommendation to
uh give a booster to 24 million five
through 11 year olds and so when you
make such a sweeping recommendation for
the entire country with such strong
vigor
ordering all 24 million children in the
country 5 through 11 to get a booster
you should convene your technical
experts instead
they put it in front of a cdc committee
which is well known to fire people who
have dissenting opinions they did that
with dr martin called cold door from
harvard last year
and the
conversation was incredible there was no
clinical data to support the booster for
five through eleven-year-olds instead
they cited a small study done by pfizer
of 140 children in that age group
looking at no outcomes but instead the
antibody bump you get after the booster
and the committee actually said we want
a simple message we're concerned about
having a confusing message if these kids
are not getting a booster and older
people are that is not a scientific
rationale
it doesn't make a lot of sense doc you
gave a great explanation there we
appreciate it dr marty mccary we'll see
what happens with both of these stories
thank you sir
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight